Rison wondering if we can talk a little
bit about life before
comrade detectives and when you were
starting out in the entertainment
industry what was your strategy did you
have a strategy did you end up here
accidentally yeah and so there's a
strategy at least I didn't know with one
eye I mean where I grew up was about as
far from the film industry as as could
be well not as give me I'm sure I could
grown up in Siberia too but I grew up in
a small village in South Wales and
really had zero idea of you know how you
might penetrate a film industry or
television and yeah it was sort of just
through lucky I mean again I think me
taking some risks and some Gamble's and
then and then some happy accidents that
I sort of found my way eventually to SML
there's a so long story between
obviously but yeah I essentially I came
I went to New York knowing again I
wanted to work in film television no
idea what to do
New York seems like the direction to
head LA felt like too much of a cultural
leap at the time and and yeah I you know
I just I had about five jobs it's sort
of my first six months hours of catering
and working in stores and all that stuff
and then luckily I got a job in a post
production facility the edited
commercials and I was working the
receptionist and that was there for up
to two weeks I think when Jim Signorelli
who is the longtime film director at SNL
as it came in to work on something and I
just thought we ended up chatting and at
at lunch time and randomly about two
weeks after that he called up and just
said the assistant was leaving and did I
want to come and work for him so that
was kind of my beginning because I
didn't go to film school I studied
theater so it was a real we're the
fortuitous place to land because the
film unit SNL is this sort of machine in
film production where we're producing
films you know from start to finish in
three days every week and when I started
they're still shooting on film as well
so it was a really amazing you know
place to land and you know suddenly be
on set and so yeah that's why I kind of
went that and then work my way up very
slowly and yeah and Here I am well
that's fascinating too from that is you
never know who you'll run into you don't
exactly be polite to strangers and yeah
I mean again it was it's there's
definitely moments when I've sort of
made a choice to you know maybe be more
aggressive or to sort of you know you
cannot you do have to assert yourself
and and you know I take chances because
I don't think you'll ever have the right
amount of experience that someone's
looking for so you know that's an L for
example my sort of let my trajectory
sort of follow the pattern the first few
years of me like the SNL season is like
a school years ago September to May and
then you have the summer off you know
and you can you know obviously go to
other things or not work but I usually
would go and work on something else and
and then each you know September would
roll around then my first few years I
never knew if I was going to get hired
again the next season but you know I'd
in every a phone call would come with
with Jim and you know I'd usually sort
of just maybe embellish a little bit
about what I'd done that summer just
have elevate my my experience so I
quickly sort of went from being a PA to
a production coordinator the following
season and then and then I was line
producer as my third year at SNL I was
line producing the film in it and
completely flying by the seat of my
pants I had no idea what I was doing and
it was way in over my head but you know
we Bo we got through it and and then I
did that for about I was the line pretty
severe for about five or six years
before I made the moves of directing and
that's a whole other thing too were you
googling things on your lunch hour like
okay how do I do this oh sure I can get
production is I will forever the design
producer position is really
is one of those thankless positions I
mean you know I commend people that that
do it enjoy it and and a good at it
because it's the to me it's on the house
jobs on set because you know you're
absorbing all of the responsibilities
that should really the sort of practical
responsibilities is you you know so if
if a PA doesn't wake up and get in his
truck and bring a camera to set or the
stage is locked or an actor doesn't show
up for you know what all the myriad of
things are the weather doesn't cooperate
it all basically comes back to you to
solve obviously the directors there
creatively to you know constantly has to
be doing the dance to solve the problems
but as the line producer obviously
that's it you know you you're the one
who's got to keep the machine running
and you know keep the budget in line all
kind of stuff and so it's really really
hard and very very stressful so I again
that was that that was the sort of the
terrifying learning experience which
sort of suddenly realizing that your
exposure was everything you know so yeah
it's I don't think it's only Google you
can only again I think some people's
personalities are made for it I don't
think I was I sort of managed to do it
for all those years and again for me it
was an amazing learning experience
because you can you you know by becoming
responsibility for everybody you
inevitably had to learn about every you
know position on set because you
obviously have to troubleshoot at any
time anyone had an issue so you get to
know you know the grit department and
their equipment needs and what they do
and the electricians and the bad
Department should so it was a really
good way just for me to really learn my
way all around within the same through
post-production again I just got really
like out of land in this weird film
school as an hour and you know it was on
on-the-job training yeah what's with the
stress of knowing that you may not come
back exactly yeah exactly so you always
kind of again you never rest on your
laurels so take everything as I will you
know I'm going to keep going as far as I
can and you know because who knows like
I might be looking for another job soon
you know like not that they encourage an
environment of insecurity but you know I
think it helps keep moving forwards you
know not to get complacent yeah sounds
like good like training right yeah so it
then doing Conrad detectives sounds like
it was much easier because I know you
shot this on spec and you had an over
to the Eastern Bloc location scout yes
yeah I would say the easier I mean I
think you know as SNL's been amazing
training I think for for a lot of
production circumstances I think I'm
more comfortable with you know the
last-minute things and sort of change it
and I think I've learnt an agility that
maybe some people don't necessarily have
to go through through working on SNL so
it helped because there was definitely
you know a sort of fish out of water
quality to accept getting to Romania and
getting to know Romanian crew
determining customs of figuring out how
this whole machine was going to work and
we had a very tight schedules ice or
ludicrously tight schedule for what we
ended up doing and and again I think
yeah it's not like Tommy the stupidity
and the naivety to to just take it on
and go for it yeah and not knowing is
actually better yeah yeah I I think I'm
have a weird addiction to to people
people freaking out around and trying to
find a way through okay well that's an
art in itself and some people are
actually really well suited for that so
yeah do you yeah I do yeah you know I
don't think I do want a battle but yes
at that time I'm good you're good at
talking people down right again
you